I know when 4ths of the cake is frosted with vanilla icing and 2 5ths of it is
frosted in strawberry icing, so I have 1 4th and 2 5ths. I need to add these two
fractions together to figure out how much of the cake is frosted in total. My
fractions do not have common denominators. I have 4ths and I have 5ths, so I
need to get the same size pieces. To find the common denominator, I'm going to
do the least common multiple method. So, I'm going to list the multiples of four
and the multiples of five. The smallest number that both four and five go into
is 20. I could also find out by using my factor tree method. When I think about
the factors that four and five have on common, the only factor that they share
is one. I know the other factor of four must be four, since 4 times 1 is four.
The other factor of five must be five. Multiplying these together, I still get
20. So I know I need to change 4ths into 20ths, and 5ths into 20ths. To change
4ths into 20ths, I need to multiply by 5 over 5. I know this because 20 is the
5th multiple of four. I also know this because I have to multiply 4 times 5 to
end up with 20. So 5 times 1 is 5 and 5 times 4 is 20. To change 2 5ths into
20ths, I need to multiply by 4 over 4. Remember, I'm still multiplying by one. 2
times 4 is 8 and 5 times 4 is 20. Now, this is great, I can actually add the
20ths together. I have 5 20ths and 8 20ths. I keep my denominator the same and 8
plus 5 is 13. So I get 13 20ths. If you chose 13 20ths, nice work.